es ist ein jahrhunderthochwasser über
200 menschen sterben die schäden gehen
in die milliarden und bei allem
schrecken kann er zumindest eine gute
botschaft vermitteln die finanzielle
hilfe kommt olaf scholz ist der mann mit
dem geld in deutschland 400 millionen
soforthilfe dazu 1 milliarden fonds für
die flutopfer für den deutschen
finanzminister kein problem es
ist wichtig dass wir den unternehmen die
jetzt vor unmittelbaren wirtschaftlichen
schwierigkeiten stehen helfen mit
soforthilfe mit der klaren zusage dass
der wiederaufbau finanziert wird damit
alles hinterher wieder so wird wie es
vor der flut war möglicherweise sogar
und in vielen fällen auch besser so dass
man auf hochwasser katastrophen besser
vorbereitet ist als
olaf scholz sich zu beginn der großen
koalition die rolle des finanzministers
bewusst aussucht kann er nicht wissen
wie wichtig das amt in krisenzeiten noch
wird auch und vor allem in der korona
pandemie generiert der finanzminister
bis dahin schier unglaubliche summen
holz liefert das was wir machen ist
erstmal ich
weiß nicht mal das hier sagen haben weil
es die bazooka mit der wehr gibt das
notwendige jetzt tun und was wir dann
noch an kleinwaffen brauchen das gucken
wir später
in deutschland kommt besser durch die
krise als die nachbarländer
dafür werden einst heilige kühe wie die
schuldenbremse geschlachtet aber stolze
nutzt auch die zeit um die finanzpolitik
auf europäischer ebene grundsätzlich zu
verändern europa nimmt in der pandemie
gemeinsame schulden auf und gibt
zuschüsse an bedürftige staaten
deutscher ist ein starkes land aber wir
haben hier unseren beitrag zur
solidarität geleistet und zum
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung in europa
von dem wir sehr profitieren in seinem
politischen leben hat olaf scholz immer
wieder davon profitiert dass er
unterschätzt wird und dass er auch
wahlen gewinnen
in hamburg wird er zweimal zum ersten
bürgermeister gewählt auch hier lag
ähnlich wie vor zwei jahren die bundes
partei die spd am boden wenn alle sagen
sie möchten dass sich die führung der
hamburger spd übernehme dann bekommen
alle das was sie bestellt hat aber auch
das was die hamburger nicht bestellt
haben denn schulzeit in der hansestadt
ist unabdingbar mit dem g-20-gipfel
verbunden der erste bürgermeister hat
ein friedliches treffen im sinne eines
hafenfestes versprochen doch hamburg
versinkt in chaos und gewalt
[Musik]
ich bedanke mich auch bei den bürgern
und bürgern unserer stadt die nicht
weniges erdulden mussten wo einige
erleben mussten dass ihre autos
angezündet wurden dass ihre geschäfte
zerstört worden sind das alles darf
nicht stattfinden es unverzeihlich und
unvertretbar seit 20 jahren spielt der
gelernte jurist ganz vorne mit in der
politik als spd-generalsekretär
verteidigt er die agenda politik gerhard
schröders als arbeitsminister setzte die
rente mit 67 mit durch viele
entscheidungen die die spd zerrissen hat
kleben auch an ihn
auch deshalb ist scholz nie wirklich
beliebt bei den genossen auf parteitagen
wird er regelrecht abgestraft noch 2017
holt er das schlechteste ergebnis aller
stellvertretenden bundesvorsitzenden im
kampf um den parteivorsitz wird scholz
schon früh klargemacht was ein teil der
eigenen partei immer noch von ihm denkt
olaf wie kann man mit glaubwürdigkeit
jemanden erklären dass derjenige der uns
letzten endes auch maßgeblich beteiligt
in funktion in dieses tal der tränen
diese niederungen der heutigen ergebnis
geführt hat heute zukünftig für
glaubwürdigkeit und soziale
gerechtigkeit in der spd steht zwischen
erklärungs problem ich bin der meinung
dass sich ein echter
truly sozialprogramm
die niederlage im kampf um den
parteivorsitz ist vielleicht die
schmerzhafteste die olaf scholz erleidet
die politischen sie auch die
persönlichen gräben zum neuen
führungsduo sind tief öffentlich wird
scholz demontiert beschuldigt die spd in
der großen koalition unkenntlich gemacht
zu haben die neue spd chefin wirft ihm
gar vor kein standhafter sozialdemokrat
zu sein
sie sind sich nicht sicher ob deren
standhafter sozialdemokrat ist in so
langen jahren der
regierungsverantwortung hat man sich
schon in
kompromisse gegeben in vielen langen
jahren die tatsächlich diese die
sozialdemokratie auch nicht standhaft
doch olaf scholz wirft selbst jetzt
nicht hin kämpft sich zurück wird gar
kanzlerkandidat seiner partei als
vorsitzender war er nicht gut genug für
die genossen jetzt soll er aber als
kanzlerkandidat gut für deutschland sein
seine kühe entspricht einem rationalen
kalkül scholz ist in den umfragen stets
der beliebteste politiker und keiner
sagt so deutlich ich will kanzler werden
ich freue mich über die nominierung
und ich will gewinnen was scholz gerne
vergessen machen möchte über seiner
kandidatur schwebt eine dunkle wolken
die wirecard pleite wirft fragen zur
verantwortung des finanzministeriums auf
die im untersuchungsausschuss des
bundestags ganz unterschiedlich
beantwortet werden und es bleibt nicht
bei einem finanzskandal
wir haben uns kürzlich noch mit dem
wirecard skandal befasst und werden das
auch weiter tun jetzt haben wir schon
wieder hier die nächste hütte die brennt
der comex skandal jahre lang sahen
politiker und finanzbeamte dabei zu wie
sich banken mit comics geschäften
bereicherten auch bei einer hamburger
bank hat der damalige bürgermeister die
beamten gezielt beeinflusst scholz
verneint für die opposition aber bleibt
ein verdacht und damit ein angriffspunkt
im laufenden wahlkampf
der aber wird erst mal von fehlern
dominiert fehler die vor allem scholz
konkurrenten machen annalena baerbock
muss sich rechtfertigen für ihre
biografie und für ein buch und armin
laschet für ein lachen im
hochwassergebiet scholz stärke
resultiert vor allem aus den fehlern der
anderen
[Musik]
auffällig im unauffällig sein könnte
eine überschrift sein die olaf scholz
und seinem wahlkampf umschreibt nichts
ist dem zufall überlassen hinter jedem
auftritt steckt kalkül so auch bei einer
veranstaltung der zeitschrift brigitte
wo er der jahrelang als scholzomat
bespöttelt wurde ungewohnt persönliche
einblicke gewährt ich glaube dass ich
ein ganz anderer mensch wäre wenn ich
nicht mit britta ernst verheiratet wäre
wir gehen jetzt davon aus dass jetzt ein
besserer mensch sind eindeutig ja
scholz vielleicht größter politischer
erfolg der letzten monate findet
weitgehend unterhalb des medialen radars
statt jahrelang hat der deutsche
finanzminister hinter den kulissen daran
gearbeitet dass es eine weltweite
mindeststeuer gibt anfang juli ist das
ziel auf dem g20 treffen in venedig
erreicht steueroasen sollen
ausgetrocknet werden tech giganten wie
zum beispiel facebook oder amazon können
sich nicht mehr klein rechnen
internationale beziehung bestehen darin
dass man sich auf das mühselige geschäft
einlässt mit vielen anderen lange zu
verhandeln geduldig beharrlich und
engagiert dinge voranzutreiben und das
ist gelungen bei der festlegung einer
globalen mindestbesteuerung wo jetzt
mehr als 130 staaten teilnehmen
das ringen um eine weltweite
mindeststeuer zeigt wie das system
scholz funktioniert beharrlich sein
ausdauer zeigen tiefschläge bis zur
selbstverleugnung wegstecken und darauf
hoffen dass man von der politischen
konkurrenz erneut unterschätzt wird